i think that
procrastination is a myth
procrastination is a word we use to
express something very natural to our
species the act
of postponing tasks since it is
something so natural
why do we even have a term for that i
don't think that procrastination
the way that society portrays it really
exists
i think it is a term we used to feel
sorry and guilty for
not being more productive than we should
but who does really decide how
productive one should be
who sets the standards of effective
productivity
for what needs to be done when and how i
think that we're all just victims of the
procrastination propaganda
and we just put pressure on the already
stressful
lives of ours procrastination is
something very natural
we're humans we're not machines we're
fragile creatures that are
designed in a very specific way our
mental and physical apparatus has limits
our attention span has limits our
intelligence has limits and
if we don't understand those limits we
will suffer
due to our ignorance all of us want to
experience a meaningful and enjoyable
life
the world is extremely complicated and
the plethora of
options and mechanisms entailed in the
worlds we inhabit
make this life more difficult than it
should be
all of us want to be creative and
productive to some degree
not because somebody told us to be that
way but because productivity and
creativity are
fundamental constituents of a meaningful
and enjoyable life
but the degree to which we decide to
embrace productivity and creativity
is predicated on our personal choices
goals and ambitions
i feel that procrastination is just used
in the wrong context
and should be approached from a
different light
so let's debunk the myth of
procrastination and discover some useful
ways to be more creative and productive
when we want to be creative and
productive
the reason we procrastinate can be
explained by understanding
two powerful concepts temporal
discounting and the path of list
resistance
i'm sure that you have probably realized
by now that humans are
addicted to momentary pleasures and
immediate brain stimulation
there is a human tendency to over or
underestimate the value of a reward
based on its temporal proximity temporal
means
relating to time so temporal proximity
is the amount of time i need
to get the reward for instance if i
offer you a hundred dollars a day or a
hundred and ten in one month from now
you will most probably take a hundred
today without the second thought however
if i offer you a hundred dollars in a
year
or 110 in a year and a month from now
you might as well reconsider and decide
to wait the extra month
human motivation is highly influenced by
how imminent the reward is
so the further away the reward the more
you discount its value
this is what temporal discounting is all
about so for you being on instagram
youtube and other procrastination
friendly websites
is more rewarding than finishing a
report or studying for an exam
on top of that whenever something
enjoyable happens you get a small dose
of dopamine which
gives you pleasure and you will more
likely repeat the behavior
video games browsing the internet this
kind of activities
provide a lot of those small doses
urging you to crave more
and that's why you find yourself
procrastinating for hours
most of the time we find ourselves
procrastinating when we face a task that
requires a lot of creativity or
something that we haven't encountered
before
this is also called resistance and
stephen pressfield has dedicated the
whole book on the topic
called the war of art resistance is
faced whenever we try to do something
out of the ordinary and it manifests
itself in many forms
it can be manifested in the form of fear
in the form of laziness in the form of
paralysis
and also in the form of procrastination
our mind whenever it needs to process
new information
it usually relies on our strongest
memories in order to draw conclusions
and give answers
everything we do in life is governed by
past experience
events in our past and specific things
we have learned
act as mental guides so we can solve
mental problems
therefore whenever we face a new task
and especially if this task
requires new forms of knowledge or
thinking
our mind fails to recognize this process
as familiar
and decides to follow the path of least
resistance
so whenever you feel resistance creeping
in don't get frustrated
it is a very natural process and it
happens to everyone
the thing is that with the right mindset
it can't be overcome
procrastination is a natural human
tendency no matter what you do
you can't always be in work mode there
are times where you just need to chill
do nothing or inject your brain with
small doses of dopamine
and that's okay your brain is not a
machine from the almost 16 hours you're
awake usually four to five hours and
maybe even less you're able to work in
deep work mode
what we're trying to accomplish here is
to efficiently use these hours
in order to finish your most challenging
tasks
and when it comes to overcoming
procrastination procrastination is not
really your problem
your mindset is your problem
procrastination should be perceived as a
reward
a reward for your hard work when you
finish your important tasks
you can allow yourself to procrastinate
non-judgmentally
and that is a very liberating feeling
the way you maximize efficacy isn't
rocket science
it is actually quite simple and
straightforward efficacy is all about
doing the right things
so whatever life scenario you find
yourself into there is definitely
one project or task in your life that
stands out and you consider
more important than others what you need
to do is give
all your attention to this project for
two to three hours per day
that's it whether your project is to
prepare for a big exam
a big presentation a pitch an
application
dedicate two to three hours per day and
you're good to go
as tim ferry said in one of his blog
posts block out
at least two to three hours to focus on
one activity for today
let the rest of the urgent but less
important stuff slide
it will still be there tomorrow
if you're going to work on your computer
you should focus on the programs and
websites
that are relevant to your work the rest
of the programs and websites
should remain closed no instagram no
twitter no news sites no email
some people suggest using apps that help
you stay disconnected from the internet
or allow you to access websites
only relevant to your work but i don't
really use them because i see that as an
exercise in self-discipline
also try to avoid meetings during that
time and if something comes up
inform the party who distracted you that
you need to contact them later
the most difficult part of every task is
the first minutes
it is the time when you face your
creative block and resistance is raising
a huge wall between you
and your ability to enter flow the thing
is that you can't expect your brain to
enter flow immediately
you need to provide it with some small
bytes of information
relevant to your task in order to
process that information
and eventually allow you to get immersed
in the activity
for example when i start writing i feel
like a crippled person with a crayon in
my mouth
a skirt to a bone good used to say the
words won't come out and i will struggle
a lot
after 10 to 15 minutes however the words
will come out
naturally the sentences will be formed
effortlessly
and the writing process will feel
extremely enjoyable
so whatever your task is start small
allow yourself to produce a not so
special result in the beginning
and once you enter flow you will be
amazed by your results
as i said it usually takes 10 to 15
minutes to enter flow
once you're there everything you do
happens naturally non-judgmentally
and with a great sense of self-worth
this happens because in flow states
we switch off our dorsolateral frontal
cortex
this is the part of our brain that
allows us to analyze and question our
own behavior
which can be highly useful but
unfortunately
it also slows everything down because it
means that all our decisions have to go
through it and it can act as a creative
barrier
by switching off this part we allow all
our attention to go to the part we want
to use
without censorship or micromanagement
this results in quick reactions and
uninterrupted
productivity flow state has fluctuations
but
once you're there you're actually aware
of it and you can become
consciously productive however because
it is a quite an energy draining state
we can't stay there long so reaching it
even for small time frames during these
two to three hours
can help us achieve great results
as we progress towards the future we
need to be careful with the words we use
to
shape our reality we all want to do
things that we find
interesting and enjoyable i don't think
that anybody
procrastinated while doing things they
find interesting and enjoyable
the problem is that we spend a lot of
time on things we don't like
just because we have to let's at least
not feel guilty when we avoid those
things
let's at least be more caring to
ourselves when we
don't feel like doing those things
hey guys so this video is sponsored by
skillshare a skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for creators
where you can explore new skills deepen
existing passions
and get lost in creativity as you have
probably realized after watching the
video
i have brooded a lot over the idea of
procrastination i am convinced that
we cannot really avoid procrastination
so
let's enjoy it by making sure that we
are productive during the hours we want
to be productive
i think skillshare is an exceptional
tool for this especially when it comes
to battling resistance and exercising
flow states
skillshare has great classes that allow
you to break through the first layers of
resistance and get accustomed to the
most critical parts of a skill
and the narrative of its class is also
very well structured and with the right
focus you can stay engaged for hours and
because i have been using the platform
extensively over the past few months
i realized that even procrastinating
because i'm on skillshare
is more beneficial than just scrolling
through my social media feed
for example this class called document
your life by nathaniel drew
which i attended after i finished my
most important tasks
for the day it really gave me a
different perspective on how we approach
uh the capturing of our live moments and
instead of just
taking random pictures or videos how to
make this process more
intentional skillset is curated
specifically for learning
meaning that there are no ads and
they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused and
follow wherever
your creativity takes you the first 1000
of you who click the link in the
description
below will get a free trial of premium
membership so you can explore your
creativity
enjoy again thanks for watching see you
soon everyone out
you